my name is Henry koya and this is my
tight talk titled hacking human language
you might wonder why it's called hacking
human language is very pretentious title
and I know that but I really love the
hecka ethics and the hecka ethics says
that access to computers and anything
which might teach you something about
the way the world works should be
unlimited and total and also to always
yield to the hands-on imperative so the
idea is to learn through doing which I
really like in which I embrace in my
studies as well so the agenda for the
talk is to talk a bit about
computational social science to talk
about natural language processing word
vector representations and I'm going to
compare different wikipedia article
revisions talk a bit about random
indexing which is another way of doing
word vector representations and then I'm
also addressing the word Tuvok patent
quickly about me on a happy European I'm
a German living in Sweden studying at a
finish University in this wonderful
European Institute of innovation and
Technology and I'm doing my master
thesis or natural language processing
and machine learning so quickly about
computational social science which is
also sometimes called digital humanities
especially here in Oxford and the idea
is basically to combine computer science
with social science and this makes new
research possible for instance you can
analyze massive social networks and you
can also analyze millions of books and
if you look at the graph down here then
this is actually all my emails so it's
27 530 7574 males and 222 people
analyzed and as you can see the green
ones are my friends from university in
Bremen the orange ones are my friends in
Stockholm and the blue ones my family
and you can also get the names of the
people but I removed it for this another
really nice research a piece of research
I like is this one and of course this is
just the map of Europe but interesting
is how it came about because this just
comes from the dot so people took the
Flickr data with the GPS coordinates and
then just plotted the GPS coordinates
and as you can see if you do that with
tens of millions of thicker photos the
European map emerged
but not only that if you don't look at
the if the at the text of the images you
also get a really good city guide you
get the eye of London you get the
Cathedral of Cologne and i found that
was pretty amazing it just goes what we
can do and you can apply these
computational means to journalism so
there's a paper called massive scale
automated analysis of news content where
they took 2.5 million articles from
almost 500 english-language news outlets
and then automatically annotated that
into 15 different topic areas and then
looked at readability linguistic up
linguistic subjectivity and gender
imbalances in regards to these topics
and it's quite interesting so if you
look at linguistic subjectivity that's
basically just looking at the adjectives
in the sentences using a technique
called part of speech tagging and I'm
going to show you how to replicate that
and do that yourself and then they have
this database the scentee wordnet it's
called which basically says that humor
is a positive word or like hey Dizz a
negative word so you took you take all
the adjectives and then you look up the
sentiment of the word and then you look
at different topics and it turns out
that fashion is much more linguistics
objective than politics elections and
business and the hypothesis they now
have based on this data is that low that
the low level of political interest and
engagement could be connected to this
lack of subjectivity because it's also a
bit more boring to read if they're not
add no adjectives another interesting
thing is looking at the female to male
ratio so they use a technique called
named entity recognition where they just
find first names and then they have a
list again of male and female names and
and this is pretty crazy and the nice
thing about this is like people might
have this intuition that there's not
enough reporting about women in sports
but now you can quantify it and you can
actually make it very very obvious
because if you do this you see that in
sports only seven to twenty five percent
of the coverage is about females and
that's pretty crazy considering that
they're fifty percent females in the
world so this is what you can do with it
and for me
it is a bit like playing lego because
you're just connecting these ready-made
blocks so you can do text processing
with n LG ke with word tyvek we're
Spacey and I'm going to talk a bit how
to use that then you can visualize it
with different JavaScript libraries
which is nice because then you can put
it on the internet you can do topic
modeling with Jensen and you can do
machine learning with the wonderful
scikit-learn so if you were to replicate
the results I was talking about you
could use NLT k and then you can do this
part of speech tagging and you might
remember that from school it's just
these are the nouns these are the verbs
these are the objectives and as you can
see it's more or less just one line of
Python or two lines where you tokenize
the words and then you do the part of
speech tagging similarly easy is the
named entity recognition where you can
see that it can actually recognize New
York City as a geopolitical entity and
this you can also use to get the names
and then another thing you might be
using which might be quite helpful is
this technology called sentiment
analysis where you want to tell if the
sentence is positive or negative and
again if you actually do what they did
in the paper and that's just looking at
single words then you won't be able to
classify a sentence like this because
the sentence reads this film doesn't
care about cleverness with or any other
kind of intelligent humor and as you see
the single words are quite positive but
the sentence is not so to do this you
can use a recurrent neural network which
was what role of was talking about today
and actually this is implemented in Java
but I think this is the best and you can
just integrate it via a subprocess if
you want to use it but the main thing I
wanted to talk about today is word
vector representations and it touches a
bit about the previous talk but I hope
it's not too redundant so the main idea
here is that words are represented by
their context so this is the famous
quote by Firth a linguist who says you
shall know word by the company it keeps
and what this basically means is that if
you take a word like banking in the
middle then the words surrounding it in
the usage
represent its meaning and that's one of
the most successful ideas of modern
statistical natural language processing
and it also enables us to represent
words with vectors and as you remember
from school hopefully what vectors are
just directions in space right so the
goal is to find just a bunch of numbers
in these directions that represent the
word like linguistics and in doing so
you actually encode relationships
between the words so the vector going
from men to women is very similar to the
vector going from uncle to own or from
King to Queen so you can just basically
just take this it's just a direction in
space and you attach it to King and you
end up almost where queen is because you
do a nearest-neighbor search in the
vector space and this holds true for
plural so there's also a vector going
from King to Queens which is similar to
King to kings and for capital cities so
you can take the vector going from Paris
from France to Paris and attach that to
Spain and then you end up in Madrid so
as we already saw on the other talk we
can do these analogy puzzle puzzles
which are closely connected to
intelligent test so you can say England
is to London as Germany is to Berlin or
all more high-level Englanders to
Cameron as Germany's to Mecca and this
also works for more linguistic things so
you have the superlative the author of
the past particle encoded and you can do
it also with more obscure things so I
played with it a bit so if i put in
Scotland and Hagar's then I get the
currywurst in Germany and I'm very happy
it's not the sour code because Kobe was
much nicer and then I told my brother
that I snuck in co he was into my
presentation but then he said you should
also do marks if you can do color Wars
so I have communism and Karl Marx and as
you can see and of course carmax is not
literally communism but if you do that
with capitalism then you have feet
monkey and haic and I think it's pretty
cool how much it can capture just from
the distribution you can also look at
the most similar words so if i put this
if i put sweden in i actually get the
nordic countries and this makes a lot of
sense because if i have a lot of sense
it's just imagine some sentences like
Sweden is a country of a lot of trees
then you can find also a lot of
sentences saying no way is the country
of a lot of trees so these are actually
quite replaceable in their usage in the
language you can also do it with Harvard
and then you get Yale Cambridge so now
I'm going to show you how to do that in
Python and it's very very easy because
we have these wonderful libraries we can
use so in jensen you have the model
store word tyvek and they are just
implementing this paper from google
title efficient estimation of word
representations and vector spaces
there's also another library which you
can use which is called spacey and
that's implementing a different model
because i just i will show you how the
word tyvek is working this is a similar
model but this takes the sentence
structure into accounts if work is a
noun or if it's a subjective subject
then that makes a difference so here is
an example of how these word embeddings
look like and again it's just the words
from the context so if you have the
two-word context window you look at
turning into banking crisis s and then
try to predict a vector for the word
banking you can also do it with a bigger
context window or you can then use it
also with this part of speech text and
like this is a subject this is the
prayer this is the adverb and if you do
this you end up with quite different
representations so if you do it with
Florida for instance if you do the
context window of 5 with word tyvek you
end up with states in cities in the
state of Florida whereas if you do it
with the dependency like this is the
subject of the sentence then you end up
with other US states and even cooler if
you do it Hawk words from the Harry
Potter universe you end up with in the
simple words of an example you end up
with Dumbledore with Malfoy and Snape
and in the dependency case which you
have through Spacey you have other
famous schools from fictional schools
like Sunnydale from the buffy the
vampire slayer universe so if you were
to use this it might be helpful to train
it on your own data and fortunately this
is very easy to
nice generator which is very memory
friendly and that took this right of the
Jensen documentation so you can use it
quite easily on your own data it just
takes a lot of time to train them if you
have a lot of data obviously if you
don't want to do that you can also get
pre-trained vectors from google so they
train their vectors on 100 billion words
and they provide 1.4 million pre-trained
entity vectors but why would you do that
why is this even interesting so one nice
and obvious application of this is
machine translation because it turns out
and again these vectors just emerged
from the usage of the words and as you
can imagine the word doc is used
similarly in Spanish as it is in English
so you basically just take the vector
for dog in English and look at the
numbers representing it and then you
take that into the vector space which
you trained with Spanish words and their
you end up with the Spanish word for
dogs you have to do a bit more like that
the paper goes into detail and how to
how to align it but basically it
actually works so how am I using it I'm
using it to compare Wikipedia revisions
so I do these free steps so I find the
word representation forward I do
dimensionality reduction and then I
visualize it and as already said i use
Jensen to find this word representation
and again it's very very easy so this is
the code i'm using this is the actual
code and this is the important part of
that code so you basically just load the
word vectors and then you go through all
the words you have and then I'm actually
keeping track of the words because I
only need the word vector ones even if
were dark us more than once and I'm also
kicking out the to frequent words
because they're not that interesting to
me and then if the word is in our model
I'm just collecting it so again this is
just what I want a high dimensional
vector this makes it look a bit more
load I mentioned that it then it is it
is a 300 dimensional vector but you
shouldn't worry too much about it
because we're actually scaling it down
to 2d anyways so that we can plot it
nicely like this and we're doing this
with TS any the T distributed stochastic
embedding which you don't really have to
implement yourself because we're lucky
and we're using Python so we can just
use the psychic learn implementation and
it's again just two lines or one line if
you want to if you really want to write
it as one and you can do so so you say
we want two dimensional vectors I'm
fixing the random state to repair to be
able to compare my results and then you
do the fit transform where you given the
word vectors and you get our
two-dimensional vectors and then you can
use d3.js to visualize it so this is how
it looks like and just to give you a bit
more of an intuition so I put in the
Wikipedia article on Game of Thrones and
then I have these regions of similar
words because similar words are encoded
similarly so as you can see this has to
do with TV series and characters and
themes and fanfiction you can also get
the bird's eye view and that's zooming
out and now you can compare different
text sources because you might see and
I'm sorry but this is very small but
that's not the point of it you have the
orange and the red ones so the orange
ones are the 2013 revision of the
Wikipedia article on Game of Thrones and
the other ones the red ones are the 2015
ones and the white one is the
intersection set and as you can see if I
toggle this a bit then it is actually
quite good it's actually quite
consistent but some words get edit and
that's where it gets interesting because
there is this section in this larger map
that has the character names and as you
can see there some character names
removed and they're also a bunch of
character names edit so this is a really
nice way to compare text sources from
the top and I'm using this to compare
books with book summaries to make sure
that the right topics are covered in my
master thesis work you can also do it
with one of your former colonies the
United States and as you can see that
one didn't change that much and yeah so
but some words were added and some words
were removed then there's one thing I
actually wanted to talk about as well
because while I was preparing there was
a lot of outrage on the internet
because there was a patent and the
patron is on the name of McAuliffe who
was also the one writing the paper and I
followed the discussion on Reddit and
it's quite interesting so there are a
lot of different viewpoints and so the
domain many people said it's just google
protecting themselves against patent
trolls others thought it was not enough
for a patent and said they could they
might as well just Payton matrix algebra
others don't like the idea of patents or
together and there is a nice post by o
Malley V who was the author of the other
paper which takes the dependency of the
sentence into account and he also said
that the novelty claim is somewhat bogos
and that at work tyvek is just doing
what the NLP community has been doing
for 25 years but very efficiently with
very good pre-processing hacks and nice
hyper parameter settings so it's just a
brilliantly efficient implementation so
yeah but the main and then there were
people saying but wasn't it released
under a patchy license and that's
exactly what thomas mcauliffe then
replied on the mailing list he said as
far as he knows it is under apache2
license which means you meet which means
we can use it as much as you as we like
and that it's just the protection
against patent trolls and there is
another good indicator that this might
actually be the case because Google has
been doing this with a dupe as well so
they have a patent on it move map reduce
but you can of course use Hadoop so
let's hope for the best there's another
similar idea called random indexing
which so basically worth of egg is
trained with a neural network whereas
this is just vector math so random
indexing is another incremental word
space model where all information is
encoded in vectors so for each word you
have a hashmap hash key which is just an
n-dimensional vector and n can be a
thousand eight hundred and then for a
very small number of these thousand
eight hundred dimensions you said minus
plus minus minus 1 or plus 1 values
right so this is kind of how it looks
like although there are much more zeros
and then so the dimensions of the
vectors
much much smaller than the number of
context and you have this hash key
representing a single word and then
every time you see a word used in a
context of another word you add the
words in the context vector to the
context vector of the word which is
pretty much the same I was just showing
you right you see banking and you see
depth co-occurring so you add depth to
the vector the hash key representing
depth to the context vector of banking
and then after if you do that often
enough of the number of occurrences this
context vector does hold information
about the words distribution so this is
a form of dimensionality reduction and
the advantages that these vectors just
just this one vector which has all the
information so you can for instance just
take the information from the Twitter
fire hose in real time because you're
not training and you're not dealing with
a neural network per se and this is what
gather guy is using and doing which is
the company of my professor they're not
only taking it to the fire hose but also
blogs and all kinds of other real-time
sources and they provide this living
lexicon so for instance last week there
was this nice news that the fillet
lender we have woke up again so at that
day I looked into how the what words
fillet is associated with so you can see
com 8a lab elapsed ellipse Rosetta
Osiris the comed trajectory so you have
this dictionary which is learning from
the current data and this is quite
interesting because you can also look at
other words like Athens for instance and
if you look into Wikipedia for Athens
you see the Hellenic Parliament you see
the Acropolis as words associated to
Athens but if you actually look at the
discussions online it's much different
people talk about grexit people talk
about the eurozone and Reno
renegotiations is one of the words that
comes up so this is quite interesting
because you can learn a lot of things
about the words and its usage but what
about more than words
where can we go from here because this
is quite simple after all the most
obvious thing is of course not only to
represent words with vectors but also to
represent sentences with vectors and to
represent documents with vectors and
luckily and happily enough you can
actually already do this in jensen there
is another model which you can use so
you can learn vector representation for
sentences and now it gets really
interesting because people also use this
to do image captioning so you use some
of the fancy models will have introduced
and you're basically combining these
word representations with a
convolutional network and then you end
up with the system that you train with a
bunch of descriptions and a bunch of
pictures so like in pairs of course so
image with its description and it learns
to represent them similarly and if you
do that long enough you are a nice
situation where you just put in the
image and get back the description and
that's literally making the blind see
which is pretty awesome and of course it
has a lot of nice applications for
company like Google's and as you can see
this works quite well so you have the
black and white dog jumping over the bar
and you have the surfer on the way for
the girl in the pink dress and even if
it is slightly off it's still pretty
cool so if you look at this this is a
gut man in black shirt playing guitar it
says here the guys tuning the guitar but
it got a lot it understood a lot about
the picture already here it says two
young girls are playing with Lego toy of
course this is not a young girl it's
more like a mother or sister and what's
really cool in this particular case it
actually got the backflip but it didn't
get the the trampoline and thought it
was a wakeboard which i think is an
honest mistake
so as you remember we have these vectors
and coding relationships as well so you
can actually do this with the images as
was shown so you can take a picture of
the touch my heart you subtract the word
day you add the word night and then you
have buildings at night it's not quite
the touch model but it's still pretty
amazing or you do a picture of a car in
blue you remove the vector for blue you
add the vector for red and you end up
with red cars so this is research from
2014 and like some weeks ago there was
another even more exciting paper where
you do image question answering so you
ask what is there in yellow in the
picture in the middle and it can reply
banana and this is super exciting and
I'm really curious where this would be
going but it's also the end of my
presentation so thank you for your
attention and you can find the slides
here on the on the website if you want
to check check them out or email me if
you have questions of course you can ask
them now as well I didn't use so the
question was what what did I use for
clustering I didn't use clustering per
se I was you I was taking these work
vectors and then was using TS any to
project them down and it's a probability
it's basically looking at the
probability distribution the high
dimensional space and the one in the low
dimensional space and make sure that
they're similar two words that are
similar in the high dimensional space
are similar in low dimensional space and
then these clusters are just emerging so
that's like the clue of my of my
summarization right ovary really
interesting so I'm afraid this is a
realistic I know why you said so since
i'll see it anyway I would
as you're showing on the diagrams the
vectors are sort of inverse the vector
from came to queen is the sort of the
same for the opposite direction as a
vector from Queen to King yeah whereas I
would think in fact the vector from
Queen to King if you're starting with
Queen should be different because as
you're going from if you get queen-
woman plus man you might get prints I
mean you can look at this country we
have Prince rather than King so you've
got slightly dictor different vector
going on because sometimes queen- woman
plus man will be king and sometimes
between minus woman plus man will be
friends yeah I think you should much
rather talk I think about it in terms of
encoding certain relationships so you
have this one encoding the gender and
you have this other one encoding the
pleura really like i like like at the
general i like the royalty like Lecter
so I hope this like are you Olaf I don't
know I was yeah yeah just depending on
your start point for the vectors whether
you would end up with a different vector
if you are focusing on queen as the
start point versus king as the Sun point
and whether it would be interesting to
see which concepts have different
relationships to each other depending on
which one you're starting like yeah you
can do that I mean you can start from
anybody to another point and that's the
direction map and then you can say well
now I have this direction right and then
take another vector and then I say oh
now I want to encode the same direction
back to what should be origin point for
this sector and the weights there is no
no actual geographical it's all about
the relative relationships there is no
global truth to it right like it's like
they're like they they can be like
colors can be close to cities or
something right but the cities will be
close to each other city names and the
color names will be close to each other
any more questions
so yeah thanks a lot and have a good day